[Music]
Saturday night on the gridiron for many
families playing American football is a
tradition one that starts at an early
age it's really fun competitive
eleven-year-old Ryan Faran Czech loves
playing the game even after suffering a
mild concussion and it's just a really
fun sport and I like to hit people
[Laughter]
but those hits even the ones that don't
cause concussions could increase his
chances of a degenerative brain disease
a recent study by the Boston University
School of Medicine found a players risk
of developing CTE or chronic traumatic
encephalopathy increases 30% each year
they play the sport it isn't so much
concussions although of course
concussions are a problem but it's also
a cumulative effect of even sub
concussive injuries the study is fueling
efforts to ban tackling under the age of
12 in some states talking about a
modification to the game not banning it
that's number one number two we're
talking about addressing children we're
not talking about adults that can
essentially consent to engage in
whatever activity regardless of the
risks hitting is part of the game in
football not an accident opponents say
the studies don't take into account new
training techniques and time limits on
drills that involve contact which many
youth leagues have recently imposed we
take the head out of the game we're
using more upper body strength hips
strength leg strength and the head is
out of it the best answer for me as a
commissioner is training football is the
most watched sport in the United States
but the number of kids who play on
school teams has been declining for the
last ten years in part due to concerns
about head injuries still for many
parents a tackle ban is a step too far
I think the prevention comes with
teaching the proper techniques in a
proper way to play the game I don't know
that a law is gonna ever you know solve
that problem I do worry about it but I
you know every bit footballs been going
on for a long time and a lot of people
play and not everyone gets hurt
the research maybe raising awareness of
the issues but these hardcore fans don't
yet see a ban as the way to tackle this
problem christen salumi al jazeera
Bridgewater New Jersey